So what happened in the
previous video?
We had a nice, simple
neighborhood in 1995.
Everyone prudently bought houses
with 20% down, they
bought it for a $100,000.
And frankly, there were probably
more people who
wanted to buy houses then but
they couldn't get financing.
And that was in place for a
reason; because you had to
prove yourself worthy to
get the financing.
But anyway, 10 years go by,
financing gets really cheap
because you have this dynamic of
rising home prices; people
downplay risk; people are
willing to give loans to more
and more people.
And they kind of do that,
just to keep up
with the other banks.
And you have in 2005, at kind
of the peak of the bubble,
someone buys house number one
for $1,000,000, with no money
down, subprime loan.
And then, a year later, they
foreclose and the house is
auctioned off and it
only gets $300,000.
But between the time that the
house was bought for a million
dollars and auctioned off for
$300,000, let's say that
that's in-- I don't know, let me
do that in year, let me say
this is 2008, now.
So 2008, this house get's
foreclosed, and
auctioned for $300,000.
And in the meantime, all of
these people-- let's say all
of them-- took $500,000 home
equity loans, right?
So they all have $500,000 of
debt from the home equity
loans, plus whatever they have
left from the original $80,000
loan, so, maybe, $580,000;
if they were only paying
interest. It may be a little
bit less than that.
Let's just say, it's
roughly $500,000.
And at first, maybe in 2008,
they all say, you know what,
this is temporary, that was just
a fire sale price, and
these auctions don't really
reflect a market reality.
So we're just going to sit tight
and wait for our housing
prices to go up because this
wasn't a real transaction.
But let's say 2009 comes along,
and this individual,
house number two's owner either
has to move, has a
different job in a different
city; or maybe they just get
laid off and they can't pay
their mortgage anymore and
they need to sell their house.
Well they try to sell their
house a little bit and it's no
coincidence that they
sell for $600,000.
And no one [? call ?]
[? line ?]
for awhile, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
starting up, because you have
a lot of people trying, at
least, just be made whole on
their loan when they sell
their house.
But no one's buying
So at some point,
they give up.
They go to the bank and they
say, hey bank, can I do a
short sale where if I sell
it for less, then I
don't owe you any debt.
But the banks are still pretty
confident then, and
they're like, no.
A short sale is when you sell
something for less than what
you owe on it.
So a short sale would be like
this guy has house number two,
has let's say a $500,000
mortgage.
And if he were to sell his house
for $480,000 and the
bank were to agree that $480,000
is all he has to pay
back, then that would
be a short sale.
Right?
But the bank says, no, you
either sell your house or
we're going to foreclo-- You
either pay us for the debt, or
we're going to foreclose
on you.
So the guy says, sure,
you know what, I
have nothing to lose.
I've just lost my job.
Here are the keys to the
house, foreclose on it.
And so the bank says, OK I
foreclosed on it and the bank
realizes in a few months that
was a bad decision.
Because now, when they auction
the house, they don't get even
$580,000; they don't get
$480,000 for it; they get
$250,000 for it.
And all of this sounds like
a very extreme example.
Things not that different than
what I'm describing happened
in places like Modesto and
Stockton, California, and
parts of Miami and Nevada
and Arizona.
But anyway, so it auctions
off for $250,000.
Now everyone in the neighborhood
gets scared
because this guy, house number
two, made an honest effort to
sell; couldn't sell; tried to do
a short sale; couldn't do a
short sale; and when the bank
auctioned, they actually
auctioned it off for
less than house
number one, it was $250,000.
So now, all these people
say, what am I doing?
I'm working three jobs to pay a
$500,000 mortgage on a house
that's probably worth
$250,000.
And if someone really were to be
rational about it, $250,000
isn't some crazy
lowball price.
They paid $100,000 for it.
Maybe, if you adjust that for
GDP growth or inflation, that
$100,000 in 2009 dollars might
be $150,000 or $200,000.
So $250,000 actually,
isn't a crazy price.
But anyway, all of these people
said, why do I keep
working so hard, being
an indentured
servant to this mortgage?
I'm just going to give the keys
back to the bank, that's
called: jingle mail.
So you give the keys
back to bank.
Let's say this guy gives the
keys back to this bank.
This bank that thought that they
had made a prudent loan,
this is house number
three, I think.
So they give the keys back
to the bank instead of
paying off the loan.
And this bank says, oh boy,
now I have this house.
They auction it off;
they get $250,000.
So what happened to the bank?
The bank had a $500,000 loan
out, it got $250,000 back.
And also, this person has also
lost all of the equity in
their house that they
originally had.
House number three
lost their house.
So how much wealth is gone
from each person's
perspective?
Well the bank had given $500,000
of real capital, real
money that could have been used
to build a factory; to
plant some crops; to work on
research and development that
might have developed new
materials or new technologies.
That was real $500,000
of capital.
And now, they got a house and
they auctioned off that house
and they got $250,000.
Right?
So they lost $250,000.
And this individual, number
one, what did they lose?
Well, they lost, by entering
into this transaction,
essentially, they lost
whatever equity they
originally had in their house.
And what equity would they
have had in their house?
Well, they had, let's just
say, they had $20,000 of
equity before they did this
transaction, right?
So they lost that $20,000
of equity.
And frankly, they could've
sold that
$100,000 house for $250,000.
We know, even in this quote,
unquote, tough real estate
market, they could have
sold it for $250,000.
So they really had, let's see,
they had an $80,000 loan, a
$250,000 asset, so they really
had $250,000 minus $80,000,
that's $170,000.
So they really had $170,000 of
lost equity, if I'm doing my
math right.
But I think you get the point.
So they did build some equity
through housing appreciation,
just the house didn't go from
$100,000 to a $1,000,000, it
went from $100,000
to $250,000.
So their equity was actually
$20,000 plus the $150,000 that
they got from just the
increasing asset value-- if
they didn't enter into
this transaction.
So they would've had a another
$170,000 of equity that they
lost. So the homeowner
lost $170,000.
So combined, these two parties,
by entering into this
transaction, how much
did they lose?
Let's see, 300,000, they
lost $420,000.
$420,000 was just wiped out.
It just disappeared
from the economy.
And where did it go?
It existed at some point, it
must've gone someplace.
Well, it was consumed.
It went into these granite
countertops and these hardwood
floors and the vacation; the
vacation is pure consumption.
You could argue, maybe, some of
it's investment if it helps
you become more productive, but
for the most part, that's
pure consumption.
Things like wood floors and the
two more bathrooms and the
granite countertops, there is
some value there, but that
value is definitely not
equivalent to the amount of
money that was spent on them.
They were depreciating assets;
they're luxury goods; they're
probably according to
the taste of the
person who did it.
But anyway, the whole point of
this video is, is when you
have these asset bubbles, like
in real estate, and you have
this downplaying of risk, and
this psychology that an asset
class can only go up.
And then people start to have an
inflated notion of what the
assets are worth, and start to
borrow against those and
leverage up against those
inflated notions, you have to
have a misallocation of wealth
and, essentially, a lot of
resources end up getting
destroyed.
Resources that could have built
factories, could have
built schools, could have built
roads, whatever, ended
up building granite countertops
and sending people
on vacation and making them feel
good to go start shopping
at Williams-Sonoma or Neiman
Marcus or whatever.
And all of that is, essentially,
just consumption
that just destroys wealth.
So it just disappears.
And I want to make this point
because we have a government
now that somehow thinks that
it can legislate away real
wealth destruction.
It thinks that, you know what,
if we just somehow buy this
loan from this bank, this
$500,000 loan, and if we were
to hold on to it long enough,
maybe the underlying asset--
the house got foreclosed on, so
we don't even have the loan
anymore, we have the house.
So maybe the government says,
oh what if we just buy this
house and hold it long enough,
maybe it'll get back to a
million dollars.
It may get back to a million, if
our population increases so
much that, one day, that might
become a productive asset
again, or becomes a
high demand asset.
Or, it might not ever go up; it
might be a house that was
built in the middle of nowhere
that's not really useful to
anyone; and, if anything, it's
going to become a place where
squatters start to come and the
whole place turns into an
empty neighborhood.
Who knows?
But the bottom line is the
government somehow thinks that
once things get bad, it can
step in and try to not let
people realize that they
have destroyed wealth.
I call that legislating
against reality.
And reality is something it's
very hard to do anything
against, whether you want to
legislate against it, or speak
against it, or perceive a
universe that's not in
accordance with it.
But anyway, this is the
crux of the issue.
But with that said, I don't want
to seem like one of these
defeatist people who says that
there's no solution to the
credit crunch.
In particular, this banking
crisis we're
dealing with right now.
In the next video, I'll give you
a proposed solution that
was actually suggested
to me by a friend
from business school.
And I actually think it makes
a lot of sense, if you think
that the credit freeze
that's going on is
the crux of the issue.